célébrer l'union européenne dans la
diversité gastronomique des 28 états
membres l'idée du marché européen
un rendez vous traditionnel pour la
commune de saint germain en laye et
c'est ce qu'on veut démontrer ici tout
est festive et populaire
le but c'est sa montre et cette
diversité richesse et cette solidarité
entre des peuples qui ont un patrimoine
d'un passé commun
parmi les cinquante exposants la croatie
derniers pays à avoir rejoint l'union
européenne en 2013 avec comme spécialité
les sirops jus et confitures à base de
cerises
un mariage qui n'a cesse comme ça qu'on
l'appelle une cerise qui est cultivé
dans la région de
nos zadar sur la côte adriatique croate
donc une région qui est très ensoleillé
et donc c'est une cerise qui est
vraiment de très grande qualité
autre pays à l'honneur les cosses avec
la ville jumelée à saint-germain-en-laye
r les écossais sont venus avec leur wii
skiller haggis et leurs traditions
culturelles musicales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mortenson droite score il y a des choses
qui peuvent marquer et symbolisé
l'écossé l'un des plus important ce sont
les groupes de cornemuse
nous avons quelques produits en
cachemire d'une entreprise locale nous
avons apporté spécialement pour cette
occasion les marmelade et des confitures
qui sont des produits clés de l'eco
l'ecosse le territoire le plus européen
du royaume uni lors du référendum sur le
bric site en 2016 64% des écossais ont
voté pour rester dans l'union européenne
[Musique]